at the age of 41 she was unemployed and
facing bankruptcy she used to be a
criminal defense attorney
today she's impacting millions with her
speeches books and coaching sessions
she's Mel Robbins and here's my take on
her top fifty rules for success volume
two alright let's kick it off with rule
number one get honest with yourself
I've always wanted a six-pack and I
don't have it and I don't know and I've
never had it and when I I finally
stopped complaining about it when I got
honest about what it was gonna require
I'm dead serious dead serious about this
at my you know at forty nine with my
affinity for alcohol and my love of
carbs and my distaste for exercise I
have a small problem on my hands if I
want a six-pack so if you were to go
forward right and think okay well if a
year from now I had a six-pack what
would what would that actually what
would my day-to-day life look like
and you can get very clear that you're
not committed to that and then you can
stop beating yourself up for this you
never intend on doing what I realized is
I can spend four minutes a day in a
hotel room or in my bedroom doing planks
and my arms look great and everybody
else will think the rest of my body is
in shape it works like a charm
so you might want to get honest with
yourself like instead of doing this be a
millionaire or do this do you really
because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
but you're gonna have to roll the clock
forward just a year and say okay if I'm
able to put $1,000 a month against my
debt I'm able to make X amount of
dollars a month I'm able to put X amount
of dollars in savings what do I need to
be doing a year from now to make that
happen and what are those habits that
are there a year from now that I don't
have right now and then roll yourself
back to this moment just like I
explained with exercise do I actually
not want to have a Manhattan tonight
nope
did I want to go to the gym today nope
did I am I willing to not eat what I eat
for grenoble am i Willa I did my four
minutes my arms are looking really good
but so bring it back and then you will
have the formula for pivoting at any
moment you time-travel forward a year
you investigate the patterns that you
have that are giving you the result that
you want and then you back your ass up
to right here right now and you decide
am I willing to do this now if I'm
willing then five four three two one
through all the excuses that are gonna
be there when you're trying to override
your operating system that's how you do
it or you have the reality check like I
had which is ocean I just like the beach
I don't intend on changing so why don't
we get this off the plate and let's
focus on the things that I am actually
committed to rule number two following
your heart and soul in the TED talk I
cited this this statistic that I had
read years ago and that is that a
scientist had calculated the odds of you
and me being born and when you think
about just even the sexual act of your
parents in a lifetime relationship the
number of times they would actually be
intimate the amount of sperm that go but
the odds of one egg and one sperm and
then you throw in then you throw in the
DNA and the uniqueness of your DNA
structure some scientists calculated all
of those odds and figured out that the
odds of you being you who you are born
the day that you were born to the
parents that you have with the DNA
structure that you have given all the
other variables that could change
something the odds are one in four
hundred trillion that you are you and so
what that means to me is that you're
meant to be here that there is a reason
why you were born and the journey of
your life is to figure it out and I
think it's actually simple I think that
life is very simple and we complicate it
because we have brains that can tell
stories and we have bodies that can
sense danger and so we over complicate
things and that the purpose of your life
is to listen to your heart and soul and
to follow it and to express the highest
version of you not
self-doubt not the anxiety not the fear
is not the pettiness not the
frustrations but to actually have the
courage to be fully expressed as like it
sounds stupid but you know as the as a
great human being to have the courage to
be kind to have the courage to be
patient to have the courage to cheer for
other people and have the courage to
tune in to that wisdom that's inside of
you and lean into it follow the things
that pique your curiosity do more of the
that actually expands your heart and
expands the amount of energy in your
body and slowly but surely if you align
all your decisions and the things that
you spend time on and the people that
you spend time on with the things that
naturally energize you your whole life
will experience a shift rule number
three use Parkinson's Law it's an
excellent question I think if you're
present to whether or not you're kind of
in the zone of time where it's cool to
be fluid you're kind of with the family
you're also sort of present on your
phone that's cool if you've decided that
because my kids are starting to complain
or my fianceé starting to complain that
I'm always like this then you got honor
that if you're gonna say I'm putting
down the phone between seven and nine
o'clock tonight and I'm actually just
gonna be present with you you've got to
honor it so what I will do is I'll just
jot a note to myself so instead of
picking up the phone
I'll just jot a note down you've had the
experience right where you gotta like be
in a meeting at the school or you have
to catch plane or you've got a doctor's
appointment and have you ever noticed
that when you've got an anchor like that
your whole day condenses and you're more
productive because you've got this
deadline and that's called Parkinson's
law
so part
since law it's a research backed fact
that when you have work to do it will
expand to the amount of time that you
have to do it so if you have 20 minutes
to make a call how long will it take you
if you have two weeks to make it how
long will it take you correct so if you
every day no phone in your room you set
that one priority that matters to you if
you got time to kind of inch it forward
just a little bit great you've already
made progress you're done for the day
then you look at your phone you also set
a quitting time right then and there the
majority of days you'll honor it and
that quitting time means for me it means
I'm not on my phone and everybody that
works for me if knows if there's an
emergency or if we have to do something
they'll call me so that that helps a lot
rule number four try if you had to pick
one word that was you one word that
represented your essence and so let me
explain what I mean by essence have you
ever been around a dog that gets wet and
they shake and then there gets all over
you that to me is the definition of
essence so you walk into a room what is
it that shakes off onto other people
what's the word right here excited
anyone else determine time energy back
in the back to shut up
thoughtful love sexy awesome
so it's interesting because the word
that fell out because I immediately
thought oh I wonder if mine is
confidence and then I thought well wait
a minute actually no it's try all I want
you to ever do is try that's it I just
want you to try in those moments where
you hear yourself I want you to try in
those moments where you know that it's
time to speak up I want you to try
that's all that I ever asked of you
because if you simply do that and I say
simply as if it's so easy right you will
literally unlock the potential of your
life if you want to learn how to have
more confidence check in my 254 series
they're free the links are in the
description below if you didn't give a
[ __ ] what anybody else thought
it's the thing you would love to be
doing with your life I know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see you might want to get honest with
yourself like instead of doing this be a
millionaire or do this do you really
because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
rule number five innovate yourself
here's another massive insight so I
always think about businesses levels
right and I also realize that is the
median landscape or the particular
vertical or industry that you're
building a business and is changing that
is a constant and it's something that
you can't control right you just cannot
control the things that are happening in
the world around us but you can always
control what you're thinking and what
you're doing in response to it so all of
my work centers inside this gap between
what's happening in your life and in
your work and what your reaction is to
it and how you can't control the things
that are going on around you but you can
always control what your reaction is and
that gap there that's about five seconds
long and you start to understand that
you can change how you think you can
change your habits you can change how
you lead you can pivot and change even
the philosophy of your company and you
can do it through the decisions that
you're making and managing your
reactions
you will become unstoppable so three
years three and a half years ago I got
into the speaking business because of
the popularity of that TEDx talk that I
gave and the first year I did I don't
know I think was like 27 speeches the
next year I did 87 last year I did 121 I
was the most booked female speaker in
the world this year I've capped it at 80
and here's why I realized just like you
may be realizing in your business
whatever your business is that there are
aspects of your business that you love
and that energize you and there are
aspects of your business that are
depleting as hell and that are old and
that are tired and that if you continue
in that lane
you're gonna end up ten years from now
in a place that you don't want to be
it's so important for you to pay
attention to
what's energizing you about the
landscape around you and about your own
business because that's the secret to
seeing around corners and so the corner
that I was seeing around is that as an
entrepreneur even though it's wildly
lucrative to do what I do just on the
speaking platform I mean anybody can do
the math on 121 speeches right and the
amount of money that I get paid to show
up and deliver a one-hour talk and
realize there's a lot of money here's
the problem it's a terrible business
because you can't scale it other than
raising your price or raising the number
of times you do it and guess what else
you have to show up and I can't sell it
so I found myself in a situation where I
had built a multi-million dollar
business highly profitable and it was
depleting the hell out of me and I can't
really scale it and I can't sell it
terrible position to be in in an
entrepreneur so I made a decision that I
you know what was it beau that actually
energizes me about my business and I
answered it with the first question it's
hearing from people I would rather
answer comments on Instagram all day
long
then stand in a stadium with 5,000
people in it I get more from the
one-to-one connection that's what fuels
me and so I had this lightbulb moment
paying attention being clear then wait a
minute I don't want to build the biggest
speaking platform and I don't want to
build a coaching business I want to
build a content company I want to go
back to my roots and build a media
company and so with that insight I now
have to change right because the kind of
businesswoman that runs a multi
multi-million dollar speaking business
is where it's just you and your speaking
management firm and your traveled folks
and your logistics people and maybe your
social media manager that's who's on the
team the kind of leader that runs that
kind of team is very different than the
kind of leader that is gonna grow a
hundred million dollar media company
that's going to syndicate content every
single day that is going to own what
she's doing that's gonna
build Instagram and Facebook and YouTube
and LinkedIn as my personal ABC CNBC Fox
and this is what I want you to
understand about the story and that is
this in order to get to the next level
in your business you got to decide right
now what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now because you
will not see around the corner you will
not engineer that next quantum leap
unless you personally change and so one
of the reasons why I have gone from
being the most successful female you
know book speaker on the speaking
circuit to launching the number one book
on all of the self-publishing platform
for Amazon and one of the most read
books in the world and selling like
gangbusters still is because I am
constantly innovating myself I know that
I am the single biggest problem in my
company and if I don't constantly pivot
and evolve how I lead and what I'm
focused on I'm gonna be the blockade and
so you know stop looking at what
everybody else is doing stop
micromanaging the team and ask yourself
two years from now when you think about
where you want your company to be what
habit do you have to change right now
rule number six be authentic
the barrier is everybody gives us what
other people are thinking
and so they're on camera or they're on a
microphone trying to be smart or
concerned about whether or not they look
good in the shot concerned about how
they sound whether or not they started
if their neck is turning red like
whatever it may be and they're so up
here that they're not actually being
true to just saying what's right here
whether you're speaking from the heart
speaking from the gut like that is the
skill to develop is the ability to be
more like an 11 year old that gets on
camera and can just be themselves
instead of being a 49 year old person
censoring themselves and that's what I'm
talking about when I talk about the
truth when I talk about authenticity
that people really want to feel that
connection and the only way that they're
going to feel that connection is if you
do the work to remove the own veneer and
the own barriers that you put in between
you and other people and the number-one
thing is everybody gives too much of a
[ __ ] about what everybody else thinks
and you know who they think they're
worried the most about the friends if I
put this thing off
not for my friends but for the people
that I'm trying to build a rapport with
online my friends are gonna judge me
your friends seriously
if your ought to make a difference if
your ought to share something that is
important to you if your friends don't
like it or don't support you there
friends the only steps that really works
is action because if you're stopping to
think about what people are thinking or
whether or not you're worried about what
people are thinking you've already
fallen into the trap the second that you
push yourself to get started you through
the action itself you are proving to
yourself that even though you care what
everybody thinks you're gonna do it
anyway rule number seven focus on what
you're good at a big mistake that we
make as entrepreneurs as we think that
we've got to build everything ourselves
and what's super cool about business
today is that there are channels where
you can make money so that you don't
have to do things that are outside your
core expertise you're a photographer
you're amazing at it you're a networker
I can already tell you're amazing at it
what you should never ever do is spend
time building a stock photography site
because that is not your core capability
but if you just focus on taking photos
which you love and you upload the stuff
that you're not going to monetize some
other way to a stock photography site as
long as it's not other you know it's not
as long as you know you've got the
rights to it and everything else you can
make money on that stuff all day long
and in fact because so many people are
creating content the stock photography
sites have exploded it's not just Getty
and stock lists and some of the other
ones that a ton of people use there
there are tons of them out there and so
that's one thing that you should be
doing where else do you want to grow
your business I want to make sure I'm
able to do that first step very well
before I progress onto the new to the
next phase okay I don't want to do so
many different things that I'm not doing
each one of them very well that's right
so anything where you're gonna have to
learn a new skill and somebody else has
done it and you can outsource it just
like uploading to stock sites that is
you don't want to make the mistake of
having your attention go off the ball
which is creating a big library of
photos and building something that you
have no interest in building rule number
eight all in your work a year ago
February 28th I believe it was we
launched a five second
and there are so many lessons in not
only the launch of that book and how I
did it as a businesswoman but also the
trajectory that has happened since then
number one it's important for you to
know that it was one of the top five
most read books on Amazon last year it
was the number one audio book in the
world it is the number one selling title
on Amazon and audible self-publishing
audible platform that's really cool
because as an entrepreneur for me
personally it's so important for me to
kind to have control of the work that
I'm doing that decision to self publish
has paid off more than it's paid off
financially and it certainly will pay
you more in the long tail financially
when you own your work and when you self
publish and if you have an idea that you
have been thinking about and you're
watching both show and you're watching
Evans channel to get the motivation to
continue to tell your story to do the
work to get your stuff out there the one
thing I'll say is if you believe in what
you're doing don't sell it to somebody
self publish it because you will
eventually it might not happen in the
first year but eventually your work will
bump into the right audience and it will
grow and it will grow and you will
really regret having sold for pennies on
the dollar the thing that was really
your life's work and so please please
please if you are content generator if
you're an entrepreneur if you're a
writer if you're a song producer on what
you're doing at least in the beginning
until you start to understand the
industry and the economics of things
rule number nine use the if-then
planning so if you're trying to stop
yourself from repeating a pattern of
behavior let's use drinking okay if
you're trying to use it to stop yourself
from drinking and you feel yourself
being drawn to go pour the glass of wine
because it's six o'clock right and you
got home and it's time to have that
glass of wine and by the way time of day
is a huge trigger for behaviors huge
trigger so you feel yourself being drawn
toward the glass of wine go five
three-two-one and physically move away
from it so that's one thing that you can
do in terms of the thoughts and we go
into this in depth in the five-second
rule book there's some science around
something called if-then planning so if
then planning will make you 60% more
likely to stick to a commitment and what
if then planning is is it is coming up
with a plan B before the you-know-what
hits the fan and so in the case of
thinking patterns that are negative or
behavior patterns like pleasing people
or silencing yourself what I want you to
do is it can be very effective to write
down all the times where you're
typically triggered to do that or to
think that negative thing then come up
with what you're going to do instead
ahead of time if this person uses that
tone of voice with me and speaks in a
different disrespectful way instead of
standing here and taking it 5 4 3 2 1
then I'm gonna do this rule number 10
walk the talk challenge with people they
know what they need to do and this is my
challenge as well yeah I know what I
need to do I know it needs to be done
right getting that motivation and
getting over that ledge and that
five-second rule and my goodness changed
my life I haven't quite made it to not
hitting snooze yet okay why let me tell
you something okay are you ready ready
your business will go to the next level
the second you actually beat the habit
of hitting the snooze and the reason why
is because of the science around
productivity and the brain okay
and when you push yourself to walk the
talk and have the first 30 minutes of
your day be the most productive for your
brain you will bring a level of
conviction and authority and impact to
the business that's not there currently
you see when you're an expert and you're
a consultant
your power is limited to the extent that
you personally feel like you're not
using the tools does that make sense I
say this for myself
I say this because when I think about
businesses that I've had in the past or
when I was an executive coach and I
would be giving advice but I'm not
technically following it in the same
regard I'm not as powerful right and so
I would highly highly highly encourage
you starting tomorrow morning you want
to be the best productivity coach on the
planet that alarm goes off notice the
gap because the more that you start to
play with this five-second window and
you go 5 4 3 2 1 and you push yourself
out of bed and you hate it and then you
take your cold shower and you hate it
and then you don't look at your phone
and you hate it and then you spend the
first 30 minutes of the day pushing
something forward and you hate it but
you do it you will now be able to coach
people who do the exact same thing rule
number 11 give yourself a push you're
never ever ever ever going to feel like
doing the things you need to do in order
to have what you want you're always
going to need to push yourself you're
always going to need to parent yourself
so what is the net advice on this what
what is the bottom line the bottom line
is no one's coming no one no one's
coming to push you no one's coming to
tell you to turn the TV off no one's
coming to tell you to get out the door
and exercise nobody's coming to tell you
to apply for that job that you've always
dreamt about nobody's coming to write
the business plan for you it's up to you
and because you're only ever gonna do
the things that you feel like doing
right now or that feel good right now
unless you understand that you've got to
parent yourself you got to push yourself
you're not gonna make your dreams come
true
you're just not we're not wired that way
you weren't born that way you weren't
that way when you were growing up and
you're certainly not that way as an
adult and there's a
tremendous amount of liberation that
comes when you accept the fact that
you're always going to need to give
yourself a push rule number 12 hone your
skills well I want to talk to those of
you that are working toward your dreams
whatever it is that you're doing right
now it's leading to the thing that you
dream of doing and you're not going to
progress until you get the skills and
the experience that you need at the
level that you're at I guarantee you
even if you're working at a front desk
job at a local gym you're learning
customer service you need to learn that
kind of stuff before you can launch your
own business for me in order to be an
incredible speaker that can command the
stage with 3,000 people in the audience
for an entire hour I first had to learn
how to have the courage to speak up and
have hard conversations in my life then
I had to learn how to speak up in a
small meeting then I had to learn how to
speak up you know in a church basement
then I had to learn how to give a little
bit of a talk at a brown-bag luncheon
then I had to learn how to stand on a
slightly bigger stage so if you're
frustrated with where you are right now
because you've got these big dreams and
you think you're really far away here's
one way that you can continue to be
patient and you can milk wherever you're
at to help you build the skills and the
experience that you need as you climb
toward the thing that you want ask
yourself what is it that I am learning
what's the skill that I'm honing by
sitting here at this front desk job or
driving this uber or lyft vehicle what
am i learning that I'm gonna take with
me on my journey to do that next big
thing because I guarantee you there's
something in the minutiae of what you're
doing right now
that you are developing an expertise and
a skill around that you're gonna need as
you launch yourself towards the next
thing rule number 13 win the morning so
here's what you're gonna do it's
actually simple and it's not gonna be
easy because you're gonna create all
kinds of excuses and drama for yourself
okay
you're gonna set your alarm for stuff
and when the alarm goes off that's what
happened that gap is gonna open up and
you're gonna feel all rolling I don't
feel like it I'm over I don't want to I
don't feel like writing a song anyway
you know like that's when you have to
take control you have to take control
you have to get up every morning it
begins by getting up because if you let
anxiety excuses self-doubt all the win
in that first decision the rest of the
day is hijacked so when the first
decision then exercise I don't care
about the eating as much I know it's
important that's put garbage in but I
would rather see you first master
getting up on time do that for a week
then let's add in exercise every day 10
minutes don't start with like two hours
because then you're gonna find an excuse
not to do it get up at 7:00 exercise for
10 minutes then the third week you're
gonna add in like I'm actually gonna eat
clean this week or whatever the diet is
that you want to eat right I'm just
gonna add in things as you master the
little things but you've got to get up
on time it starts right there blue
number 14 become a great problem solver
you know we all face problems in our
lives it's just part of being a human
being but if you ever considered that
there are really only two kinds of
problems that you're ever gonna face
there are temporary problems and then
there are permanent problems that are
more like conditions that you have to
learn with now a temporary problem is
something that you have tremendous power
to change and permanent problems though
are something that require a different
skill and that is the ability to just
accept things as they are and let the
complaining go now one of the skills in
life that is really going to help you
become a great problem solver and it's
also going to give you more control over
your life is knowing what kind of
problem you're actually dealing with
because we all complain about our
problems but to actually solve a problem
you got to understand what kind of
problem you're dealing with the truth is
you can't change a permanent problem so
no matter how much a complain about it
how much you try to change it how much
energy you put into it
nothing's changing it's a waste of your
time and your energy to focus on those
now when you try to change a permanent
problem you know you aren't stuck
because you feel like you're just
spinning in circles temporary problems
or what you want to focus your energy on
these are the decisions and the life
choices that you keep making that might
feel good in the moment but they
actually make you miserable now here's
the thing about temporary problems
they're not permanent you may hate your
body but you can change it you may hate
and be unhappy in the relationship that
you're in but you can change it you
might complain a lot about how your boss
treats you or how you feel passed over
at work but you can change how you
interact with your boss and you can
change how you show up at work and you
can even change your job that's the
difference between a temporary and a
permanent problem temporary problems you
can change now here's an a simple
exercise that I want you to do I want
you to make a list of all the things
that you complain about maybe you
complain about your commute where you
live the person you're with your health
your boss the amount of money you have
now I want you to look at every single
complaint you have and ask yourself what
can I do to change this problem what can
I do to fix my relationship with your
boss because you can't change your
bosses personality but you can
definitely change how you interact with
her and when you change yourself and
your own behaviors and how you think
you're gonna change everything
rule number 15 Act I've always been very
scared and lack of confidence and
thought that I was never good enough
flex some of my partner's hold on we've
all bought into a lie we've bought into
a lie that confidence is belief in self
and so when you're in a situation which
is normal where you don't believe in
yourself you're like oh my god I have no
confidence the truth is and I want you
to walk out of here with a new
definition of confidence confidence is
the willingness to try because when you
try and you take action what happens and
what's happened for France is that when
she sees herself taking action what
happens is she sees herself being the
kind of person that takes action so she
has ever
dents that she can rely on herself and
that action is what builds confidence it
doesn't start with belief the real way
the real way for most of us is not to
wait to believe but to push ourselves to
act and through the action you will
build the belief rule number 16 use a
brain dump so let's pretend that this
right here this empty mason jar is your
brain in order to do your best thinking
you need to make sure that you've got
the full capacity of your brain
leveraged and pointed at the things that
are important to you here's the problem
when you go through life as you go
through life what happens is you know
your brain starts to fill up with
information and that's what creates a
state of feeling overwhelmed being
overwhelmed is nothing more than having
a full brain so as you go through your
day-to-day life and you start checking
email and looking at texts and looking
at Facebook and sitting in meetings and
flipping through television channels and
sending emails and writing Excel
spreadsheets and running and picking up
the kids at work and getting another
text and looking at Instagram and
looking at Twitter and checking out the
news your brain gets pretty full doesn't
it and so when you feel overwhelmed what
I know about you is that your brain is
full of a bunch of garbage and so oh I
didn't think about the drain draining I
hope that's not bothering you but it's
certainly got to bother me what you need
to do in order to fight overwhelm is
you've got to actually do a brain dump
you got to get rid of all that stuff so
that you've got an empty brain so you
can focus again so how do you do that
it's easy to do with a cup of water
because you just pour it up this is what
you're gonna do you are literally going
to dump out everything that's in your
head onto this piece of paper every
concern every worry every to do every
thing that's bothering you that you're
thinking about you're gonna write down
[Music]
all right and when you're done writing
down everything that's in your head and
there's absolutely nothing left oh I've
got something due tomorrow that I kind
of forgot about once you get that stuff
all down on a piece of paper pull out a
highlighter take a look you could do
everything on this list you could but
what should you do what are three things
just three that you should do in order
to advance the things that matter to you
let's see I got to do that one I got to
do that one and I got to do that one the
rest of this list is complete and other
garbage it's other people's stuff it's
the email stuff it's the meeting stuff
it's the stuff that's not all that
important to me it's not that
mission-critical
so by dumping everything out I now not
only have the three things I need to do
I've got a clear head so I can get it
done rule number 17 go for it if you're
about to do something for the first time
chances are high that you might
embarrass yourself but what it means is
if you're willing to be the kind of
person that is willing to embarrass
themselves it means you're trying
something new it means you're going for
it when everybody else sits on the
sidelines and so one of the things that
I would encourage you to do is that when
you feel that tingling like you're
starting to hold yourself back because
you start thinking about what all your
friends are thinking about that's a
moment to go oh this is what that lady
was talking about five four three two
one I'm going for it the red 18 stop
procrastinating you're not a
procrastinator you have a habit of
procrastinating big difference because
if it's a habit I can teach you to use
science to break it you see all habits
have three parts there's a trigger and
in the case of procrastination the
triggers always stress then there's a
pattern you repeat and in the case of
procrastination it is to avoid doing
something and then there's a reward you
get a little stress relief the only way
to break a habit you guys is not to deal
with the triggers you're never
gonna get rid of the stress in your life
but you can 100% change your pattern of
avoiding work so next time that you're
in a situation where you feel yourself
hesitate you spent way too much time
checking out the highlights from last
night's scores what you're gonna do is
you're gonna go up I must be stressed
out about something acknowledge the
stress then go 5 4 3 2 1 I want you to
count to yourself because I want you to
interrupt the habit that's stored here
and I want you to awaken your prefrontal
cortex then I want you to just work just
for five minutes the reason why I want
you to only work for five minutes is
because your problem isn't working
it's the habit of avoiding I just need
you to start and here's the other cool
thing we know based on research that if
we can get you to start 80% of you are
going to keep going rule number 19 make
the best decisions if your friend is
facing a problem when you have to make
decisions on behalf of your friend you
tend to think from multiple perspectives
you think about multiple outcomes and
ultimately you make a much better
decision what they found research though
is if they put you in the exact same
situation facing the exact same thing
that your friend is you're not able to
be so objective because you're emotional
and you don't make that creative
decision what's the conclusion well when
you make decisions for other people
you're great when we make decisions for
ourselves decisions that can be
emotional we're not so good at it that's
where the power of objectivity comes in
it's the ability to make a decision from
a third party's perspective let me
explain so if you're facing a really
important decision and you can feel
yourself getting emotional maybe you're
thinking about asking for a raise or
changing your career or changing your
major or ending a relationship or
starting a relationship whatever it may
be if it's something that is emotional
for you you're gonna have a hard time
thinking about all the options and
you're gonna be really attached
emotionally because maybe you're
concerned about the people who may be
impacted by your decision maybe you're
managing that somebody's gonna be
disappointed or hurt by what you need to
do for you this is when the power of
objectivity is really important pick
somebody that you really admire
I mean it could be somebody like a Bill
Gates or a Richard Branson or an Oprah
Winfrey or maybe have a mentor and stop
yourself and ask what would Oprah do in
this situation what would Richard
Branson do in this situation what would
your mentor do in this situation
bringing that level of third-party
objectivity will yank you out of your
body and your emotions and it will help
you give yourself the perspective that
you need and the distance from your
emotions so that you can actually assess
your options and make the best decision
for you what would Mel do if Mel were
making this decision the best decision
you know there's a really interesting
example of somebody who did this in
sports and at the time he actually got a
lot of flack for it it was LeBron James
now LeBron James as you know played for
the Cleveland Cavaliers for a really
really long time and he's arguably one
of the best basketball players to ever
hit the NBA so he made this announcement
that he was going to leave the Cleveland
Cavaliers where he had been playing for
ever had rabbit rabbit fans and who's
gonna leave them and go to Miami Miami
Heat
that was the conclusion you woke up with
this morning that was the conclusion I
what was his morning he was giving an
interview to ESPN and what he said was
this he said LeBron James needs to do
what's best for LeBron James
now people kind of laughed at him
because it's a funny way to say the
sentence but this guy's really smart he
was leveraging the power of objectivity
Mel Robbins needs to learn how to do
what's best for Mel Robbins and you need
to learn how to do what's best for you
rule number 20 write things down I think
I'm stuck one is that I have a bazillion
ideas about things that I can create and
do in courses and trainings and la dee
da dee da who can relate and so actually
moving from the idea and even creating
the whole curriculum and all of that to
actually making it happen
yeah and doing it so I have a cool
strategy that I use and I hope that
works for you so I carry a little
notebook and I actually borrowed this
from Chris because when we lived in New
York City he used to carry around a
notebook like this size and whenever he
had an idea he'd just jot it down then
he'd stick it in his back pocket
and it was just full of all kinds of
stuff so I carry around a notebook and
this one's new so it doesn't really have
much in it as ideas come I just jot it
down in that notebook and then what
happens for me is I get anxiety because
I'm afraid that I'm gonna forget the
idea then that anxiety makes me get
distracted and unfocused and overwhelmed
and so I think if you were to have a
little notebook on you at all times
and when those creative juices and those
impulses go that you jot them down
that's gonna remove one layer of the
over oil
rule number 21 chase energy I think you
should chase what energizes you everyone
talks about passion legacy purpose yeah
the one word to pay attention to his
energy I love that that's it let's
simplify this okay so whatever energizes
you naturally expands
feels like possibility is exciting to do
and maybe scary that doesn't matter
it has to do with how it makes you feel
right when you were in your 20s money
made you feel good it expanded you it
energized you chasing the money that was
the game that was your passion that was
your per there's nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with that and I
particularly want to say that to the
women that are what yeah because it is
socialized into women not to chase
success like that not to go after the
money and so if what energizes you is
amassing wealth go for it but what
happened and and the reason why I say
that is because people talk about the
word passion yeah or purpose right and
the truth is it's not a person place or
a thing it's not it is the feeling of
being expanded and energized great if
you're pursuing your passion it means
that you wake up every day and are
energized so instead of trying to think
what's my purpose what's my passion was
my purpose what's my passion
yeah instead of thinking like that I
want you instead to ask yourself what's
what could I do today that would
energize me
what energizes me if it's making money
figure out how to make money if it is
making a difference figure out how to
make a difference it could be in any
single shape or form but if it energizes
you that's what you need to follow and
what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time because when you first start making
money it's thrilling yeah
thrilling there is nothing more
exhilarating than making your first
million yeah nothing more exhilarating
but what happens is once you learn how
to do something once you can do it over
and over again and so it starts to
become routine yeah which means it's no
longer energizing right which is why
every entrepreneur out there goes
through the mode of chasing the money
and then you hit the money that you need
to make then you're like I'm not
fulfilled yeah do that
finally oh you know I did that yes yeah
and it's because you were energized by
the money and now you're not yeah now
you got to be energized by the next
thing blue number 20 to see your friends
more it turns out that one of the best
stress relievers on the planet is
something that most of us don't ever do
and that is seek out time with friends
when we feel totally stressed out when
you're doing twice as much work as you
normally do or you're feeling twice as
much stress as you normally feel studies
at Harvard show that what you need is
you need to see your friends twice as
much now Sean anchor is a really famous
researcher and best-selling author at
Harvard and he studied this phenomenon
he looked at at people that were
stressed at schools and in call centers
and in the military and in banks and in
almost every single industry what he
discovered is that the most successful
people the people that were the best at
selling the people that there were the
most resilient the people that had the
best ability to deal with stress when
times got tough were the ones that saw
their friends the most it was the people
with the tightest social connections
that had the ability to weather the
storms that life throw at us I want you
to write down three people three people
that when you hang out with them you
you'll energized that when you have
plans with them you're excited about
seeing them when this video ends reach
out to them that's right pick up the
phone send them a text I want you to
invite them to do something go out to
lunch go for a walk in the woods get a
cup of coffee go out to dinner even if
you're not stressed out I guarantee you
at least one of the three people that
you're gonna reach out to needs you room
423 be with the right group of people be
interested in what you're really
interested in or the easier route
honestly dropped the popular kids and
find your people you need to find your
people and your people are the kind of
people that the second you hang out with
them you don't feel like less of
yourself you feel like more of yourself
you don't feel like you got to hide or
be somebody else you feel like you want
to express yourself and show up and be
more of yourself that's the indication
that you have found your people rule
number 24 change your story well you
want to know the secret the secret to
helping any human being it's actually
really simple the secret is to ask
somebody where they're in conflict
internally like what are the things that
trigger you what are the things that you
complain about what are the things that
you're afraid of that internal conflict
holds the secret to solving everything
and becoming a better person and all you
have to ask yourself or ask somebody if
you're coaching them is what happened to
you
now what's wrong with you but what
happened to you that you believe you
don't matter what happened to you that
you believe that you're not good enough
what happened to you that you believe
that you're not worthy or that you won't
be a success right and everybody has a
story and here's the interesting thing
you don't have to find the first one
because what happens in life is
something happens to you whether you are
a victim of abuse or you simply are in a
classroom when you raise your hand and
you say the wrong answer in math class
and everybody laughs and then you're
like oh my new strategy is I don't talk
in class my new strategy is I'm
introverted and shy
that's - strategy because I'm going to
protect myself and it works it works
because you don't raise your hand and
then nobody laughs at you but over time
you start to feel that sense of like I
there's something more why am I not
talking why is and so you start to have
a conflict with that strategy and so the
thing that you'll see is that human
beings repeat behavior so if you ask
somebody what happened to you that made
you start to doubt yourself they'll
start to find 10 or 12 or 20 examples of
it because it's everywhere and when you
finally start to address what happened
you can now have the self-awareness to
create a new story to start a new
chapter you know to see the old strategy
and now consciously you talk about
consciously creating consciously create
a different response that's what I do
for people I am helping people identify
the internal conflicts that are making
them miserable that are ruining their
relationships that are destroying their
self-esteem and then once we highlight
those we pick a different strategy look
that's what we do and you know anybody
can do it any age rule number 25 assume
good intent today for the next 24 hours
I want you to assume that everybody else
around you has the best intentions the
person that cuts you off in traffic the
friend that's not texting you back the
customer that writes an email that has a
snarky tone whatever it may be the fact
that you may be riled that you posted
something on Facebook and and one of
your best friends didn't tag you in it
or didn't like it I mean we get hung up
around the stupidest stuff but today I
want you to assume the best intentions
you know this recently happened to me
where I really had to put this to use I
had a situation at work where I had a
conference call and it was related to a
speech and it was one of these kind of
kickoff calls or a bunch of people on
the client side are gonna be there and
we're gonna talk about the event and I'm
gonna talk about the speech and during
the conversation this conference called
I said something that I didn't mean to
say I was totally responsible I
basically said what day am i speaking
now I knew the date that I was speaking
what I didn't know is in the flow of the
event was I the opener was I the closer
was I the person that's supposed to be
the defibrillator after a big lunch like
what role am i playing that's a really
important thing to understand if you're
giving a speech because it helps you
customize what you're going to do well
the client misunderstood me because I
wasn't precise and they were annoyed
because they thought holy cow we've
we've hired this person we've sent her
all kinds of information she doesn't
even know what day she's speaking so the
client gets upset they complain to the
event planner
the event planner then writes me one of
these emails it's like this long the
planner was really upset because I had
made the planner look bad in front of
the client now fully my responsibility
completely unintentional and also based
on a gigantic misunderstanding so what
did I do
well I did exactly what you should do
when you screw up I took total
responsibility I apologized I went
overboard and cleaned the mess up I
wrote a long email I actually left
voicemail messages when we had to
deliver a bunch of things I went
overboard and being great about it and
you know what I got from the planner
that was really upset with me I didn't
get an email back I didn't get a phone
call back even though I had a requested
one nothing nothing nothing nothing and
of course what happens when somebody
doesn't respond to you whether it's
somebody that you're dating or it's
somebody that's a good friend or it's a
customer or somebody that's upset with
you and you've apologized you
immediately think that you've done
something wrong we even do it if you get
an email and somebody's tone is slightly
off it is bananas how quickly we assume
mal-intent we assume we're in trouble we
assume we've done something wrong so
what did I do in this situation because
my reaction was I was disappointed that
I didn't actually get a nice email back
or a hey no problem let's move on and
have a great event just got silence what
did I do I use the five-second troll
five four three two one when I catch
myself thinking about it and then I
assume positive intent
I tell myself a different story I say oh
well I've apologized twice so maybe the
planner feels that everything is
complete and taken care of and no need
to discuss it further I also assume hey
this event is a big event I'm sure
they're SuperDuper busy and this the
last concern on their list another thing
that you can say is maybe they're busy
maybe this isn't a big deal to them
maybe I've already been forgiven rule
number 26 interpret nervousness as
excitement oh great excellent
I hope you and something you're never
gonna feel ready to speak up okay and
for the group for girls in particular
super important visibility you don't get
credit for things people don't see and
so raising your voice and learning how
to do it in a classroom before you get
into the workforce before you got to
raise money so important and so what I
want you to know is you're never if
you're somebody who's like introverted
or somewhat shy you're never gonna feel
comfortable doing it but you've got to
do it your dreams depend on it what
happens in your body when you're about
to raise your hand okay and what does it
feel like in your body okay is your
stomach hurt or is your throat tight
it's your chest get a rash like mine
used to i'll see you're lucky okay what
about your hands they get clammy yeah
okay so the main thing to do is when
that happens just go oh that's a thing
that was talking about my body is
getting ready to talk so before I give a
speech I give about a hundred speeches a
year do you know what happens in my body
my stomach hurts my armpits are like
Niagara Falls my hands are clammy my
throat is tight
I'm gonna talk do you think I'm nervous
exactly my body is getting in a state to
do something that's why and excitement
are the exact same so the next time
you're in a class or you're with a group
of friends and there's something you
want to say tell me what happens again
in your body your stomach starts to hurt
what does it mean yes what does it mean
on a positive side yes you're getting
ready to talk I love that so that's the
way that we're going to re label that
tape in your mind my stomach's in knots
okay I'm not nervous I'm getting ready
to talk here we go that's that signal
Mel Robbins said she gets it in the
stadium I'm getting it right now five
four three two one I'm going ruling with
27 make energizing decisions any
decision can be divided into what do I
need to do versus how and when do I need
to do it for the what that is intuition
and by intuition I use the word energy
and the way to answer any question for
yourself personally that you don't
immediately know the answer to is to ask
this question does it energize and
expand my life or does it drink it if it
energizes and expands your life the
answer is hell yes you should absolutely
do it that is what you should do if the
decision shrinks you or it deflates you
then the answers hell no you should not
do it this is an incredible tool to use
in deal-making by the way because you
know I'm in the middle of negotiating a
massive media deal at the moment and
it's something I've always wanted to do
yeah and when you're negotiating for
something you really want whether it's
somebody that you're dating or you know
it's a salary or whatever it in my case
it's a massive media deal you can get
really ego driven right right you can
start to get very attached to the deal
or to the person whether the whatever
but you have to stop and ask yourself is
this deal or this person actually
expanding but and energizing are or are
there aspects of it that deplete and
shrink me and if there's any aspect of
it that depletes and shrinks you either
have to change that aspect of the deal
or the relationship structure where you
have to say no period right if you
decide that yet it energizes me and I
really want to do it then that's what
you want next you've got to think about
the outcome which is how and when you
make it happen
rule number 28 value your own attention
have you ever heard the term attention
economy if you haven't heard it you're
gonna start hearing it a lot because
that's what we live in right now it
means that people and companies make
money than they have your attention and
in the world of Internet technology
social media your attention is for sale
and what I want to do in today's
mentoring session is I want to shift
your attitude about how you value your
own attention so got a simple question
for you do you use a phone or a computer
to make money or to improve your life or
does the phone use you to make money
what look at this I lifted it up and it
started playing a video check it out
it's on Facebook right now every time
you are on your laptop and you go onto a
laptop and you start scrolling
mindlessly through Facebook someone else
is making money you ever thought about
that I kind of just scroll through
Facebook right now ooh here's a post
about yoga tights I don't need oh and
here's something from BuzzFeed about
cute group photo of 23 baby pan is
trying to make you know who's making
money right now whoever made this video
and so is BuzzFeed and so is Facebook
but I'm not they're making money off my
attention and as I keep scrolling oh
here's somebody that's doing something
related to the news and here's another
thing
ooh chocolate chip peanut butter cup
lasagna cake am I making money and I
improving my life pirate no but guess
what
tasty video is and so is Melissa's
southern style kitchen who plots
this post so why am i pointing this out
to you I'm pointing it out to you
because the engineer's at Facebook the
engineers at every website they they
understand something they understand
that the longer that you spend on their
website or reading their emails or
clicking their stuff the more money
they're gonna make see you and I are up
against a massive amount of Technology
and people that want to trick us into
giving them our attention there's a
reason why Facebook has an algorithm
where they put things in your newsfeed
that you like it's because research
shows that you'll actually stay longer
and how does somebody make money in the
attention economy well they make it by
grabbing your attention so I want you to
consider something today I want you to
be really mindful about your attention I
want you to be mindful about how you're
using your phone and your computer are
you using it to get ahead and to make
more money and to do the things that are
important to you or are they using you
to make a buck as you're going about
your day just notice am i picking up my
phone
to use it to improve my life or make my
goals happen or am i picking up my phone
and letting somebody else use me to make
money rule number 29 get real with
yourself
you said into the microphone that you
think you're not good enough so how does
thinking that you're not good enough
stop you from taking the action you need
to take I have an embrace technology
okay
now we're somewhere
[Applause]
I know why I know why the reason why is
because it's not that you don't think
you're good enough you don't think
you're smart I'm an eight-track man and
the thing that's underneath I'm not good
enough is you actually believe you're
not smart enough and so you avoid the
things that scare you and you have a
very you know fabulous personality I
love that you're making jokes about the
fact that you're an eight-track man but
the reason why and I do the same thing I
make jokes about I want to deal with
either because it's easier it is scary
to say I don't know how to do this and
I'm scared if I actually pivot and start
focusing on technology because I need to
then I'm not going to know how and so
it's easier to be busy and it's easier
to be on television stations and it's
easier to try to do all this stuff that
feels good because it's in my wheelhouse
and so what I want you to really take a
look at is where does my story that I'm
not smart where is it blocking my dream
where is it lying to me because you are
smart and here's the other thing you
don't have to be smart you have to work
hard and you work very hard and you are
very committed but there are things that
you know you know how many are you
relating to this conversation look
around you are not alone there are
things that you know that you must focus
on but it scares you because it triggers
that button in you I just got a PhD
that's it I hope they don't find out I
don't know what the hell I'm doing oh my
god oh my god how do I know this is what
you're thinking cuz it's what I think I
want you to look at where in your life
that story is robbing you of your dreams
and where it is giving you an excuse to
avoid the things that you know you need
to do okay what did you just get from
our conversation I got that I need to
meditate and see exactly why I might
take an action and start you know doing
it and embracing it and I'm
I'm more than no rule number 30 use the
5 second journal Isle of vision boards
and gratitude journaling because they
help me think about what I want and why
this journal it's gonna teach you how
how you make your dreams come true
I created this journaling method a
couple years ago because I wanted to
stop thinking about what I wanted and
actually make it happen this is simple
it's backed by science and it's gonna
help you make your dreams come true with
just a couple minutes every morning let
me show you how it works
at the very top you write down the time
place and date this simple trick gets
your present and grounded in the moment
now notice this is guilt free journaling
there are no dates printed so if you
miss a day or two you're not behind next
I'm gonna give you a superpower this my
friend is your inner compass learning to
read your energy is the secret to
greater passion productivity and living
with more purpose research from the
University of Pennsylvania proves that
if you boost your mood in the morning
you actually increase your productivity
all day long these next two questions
will help you take control of your
energy which changes how your mind
perceives tasks and will make you more
confident about the day ahead and this
section right here it's the secret to
having a great day I want you to
identify one project that matters to you
today not two not three just one when
you focus on just one project a day you
leverage the progress principle it was
invented at the Harvard Business School
and it will change your life and help
you be more productive so you can make
your dreams come true research proves
you get more done when you focus on less
and every day I want you to focus on
just one thing after you write down your
top project I want you to write down why
this project matters to you when you
know you're why science says you're
gonna be more inspired and motivated to
get it done now take that vision and
make it your mission write down one
small action that you're gonna take
today to move your dream forward it
doesn't matter how small it is forward
is forward according to research simply
using this section of the journal makes
you 76 percent more likely to go from
dreaming to doing and if you have any
other thoughts about the project here's
some extra space to play around with
when you move from thinking to doing it
may make you feel overwhelmed so let's
change that attitude with a little
gratitude studies prove that grounding
yourself and something that you feel
grateful for will boost your happiness
and your effectiveness finally I want
you to write down your quitting time yep
you heard me right part of your morning
routine should be deciding when you're
gonna stop working at night if you feel
like your wheels are spinning and you
don't get anything done if you have no
balance between work and life if you'd
love to spend more time with your family
and still feel like the most productive
person you know set a quitting time this
is called Parkinson's law and it's
rocket fuel through your productivity
now let's go over to the next page
everyone works differently so this page
is designed to work for you if you love
making long to-do lists and checking
things off here's the spot if you want
to plan out your day there's a time line
on the left and if you need a place to
take notes here's a place where you put
them so there you have it the five
second journal rule number thirty-one be
responsible for yourself if you're going
to follow influencers and you're going
to look to other people for advice
remember one thing would you actually
trade lives with them would you actually
want to do what they're doing yeah with
their life and if the answer is yes then
listen yes but then always come back and
reflect on whether or not that advice
feels true for you yeah and adjust it
because the things that I'm saying they
work for me and I know they work for
millions of people but they might not
work for you based on your mental health
based on your financial situation based
on what's going on with your family the
timing might not be right you might not
be mentally capable of doing these
things without professional help
so you have to be responsible for
yourself yeah that's the most important
thing about personal development rule
number 32 do it anyways do it anyway is
a mindset trick that you can use when
you start to feel excuses rolling up it
works a lot like the five-second rule so
you
have said to yourself okay I'm gonna
talk to my boss today about that thing
that I've been avoiding talking to them
about or maybe you've said something
like I'm gonna go to the gym today or
tomorrow or whatever and then the moment
comes where you've got to have that
conversation or the moment comes where
it's time to pack up your bag and leave
your desk and go to the gym and what
always happens you don't feel like it I
bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that yeah
I'm not gonna have a drink tonight and
then guess what happens when you get
home you don't feel like not drinking
you feel like having a drink and so
here's what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway has
pushed me to realize and to recognize
that there are a lot of moments where
there are things in my life that I
really want to do I need to do I should
do but when the moment comes I don't
feel like it and so I pull out this idea
of you know what I'm just gonna do it
anyway it's raining outside I said I
would go for a short run I don't feel
like it I'm gonna do it anyway it's six
o'clock in the morning I'm tired it's
cold I laid out my yoga clothes but now
I don't feel like it what do I do I do
it anyway
when you start to say to yourself I'm
gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you you acknowledge them and you
basically say guess what I'm gonna do it
anyway
rule number 33 focus yourself the
businesses that were launched by
somebody like you who was working
full-time while launching your business
had a 33% less chance of failing than
the people that quit their jobs and jump
all in and the reason why is you know
how to hedge your bets you're a little
conservative in terms of the risks that
you'll take which means over the long
term your business is more likely to
succeed you asked me how do i balance my
passions how do you find the time
because I like you have a million things
going on from being an on-air
commentator to CNN to having an
incredible partnership with Success
Magazine and doing a ton of cool stuff
with them to giving over 80 speeches a
year and running a company and having a
family the key is this you must find 30
minutes before 7:30 in the morning 30
minutes before 7:30 that you take at
home that you take at a coffee shop
where you organize your day and you work
on two things that will push your
business forward 30 minutes before 7:30
why do you need to do this well because
when you walk into work your days likely
gonna get hijacked and secondly if you
were to take this time every single
morning and focus yourself you're now
starting your day having already done
work to advance your business and you're
walking into your current job knowing
what you need to get done that's gonna
make you work smarter at work I think a
lot of people that are working a job
full-time and also trying to launch a
business on the side actually have the
time the problem is that you're not
being rigorous and focused about what
you're spending it on rule number 34
follow the energy follow the energy yet
because if my husband hadn't gotten into
a business blow up in Boston I'd
we'll be in New York City making $19,000
a year is it as a legal aid attorney
that's what I'd be doing because I loved
I loved being a fighter for people that
didn't have people fighting for them I
loved that and I still do that today
right the people that I our audience are
people who want to do better it's people
that want to be happier people that want
to do more for their families people
that want to pursue their dreams and I
am fighting I'm fighting the Bulls for
you
yeah I'm fighting yourself doubt I'm
fighting your anxiety I'm fighting your
excuses I'm fighting the stories that
you've had since childhood and I show up
every day to remind you of who you are
right and to remind you that you can do
this if you put in the work and if you
give up your timeline and if you're good
to people and if you're positive and if
you cheer for other people and the fact
that our platform has grown so fast and
our engagement is so big makes me better
at what I do because we literally hear
from a thousand people a day who are
either struggling yeah or who have used
some small thing that we've said and it
has improved their lives or their
relationships and that makes me not feel
I do that energy it gives me energy
thank you it doesn't go here it goes
here you know what I mean yeah rule
number 35 master visualization if you
expect to achieve your goals if you
expect to reach your potential if you
expect to have your dreams come true
what about to explain to you is mission
critical you must become a master at
visualization now for those of you that
are like what the heck is she talking
about I did not sign up for some sort of
meditation woo spiritual thing here
don't worry this is Mel Robbins
there's always science and research
involved in everything that I talk about
so visualization is a extraordinarily
powerful skill and you may have heard of
the law of attraction you may have heard
of the word visualization you may have
heard of the word manifesting I call it
seeing signs so I'm a master at seeing
positive signs I am a master of creating
coincidences I have the world's most
incredible luck you want to know why
because I understand the science and the
skill of visualization I know that your
brain it is a gigantic detective machine
your brain is a filter your brain is
constantly looking for evidence and
that's good news it's good news when you
know how to use it to your advantage
let me explain so your brain has a
system in it here's the technical term
it's called the reticular activating
system it is a network of neurons all up
in here and what is the job of the
reticular activating system it is a
filter system it's basically a system
that allows certain information in your
brain and it blocks out other
information and guess who programmed
that filter you did and so did the
people from your past
and so if you constantly feel like
you're unlovable guess what your
reticular activating system is going
through the day and it is going to point
out every single piece of evidence that
confirms that negative belief that you
have if your goal is to improve your
self-worth I want you to visualize what
your life looks like and how you're
going to feel about yourself when your
self-worth
has improved here's how you're gonna do
it so there's two things that you have
to do when it comes to visualization you
have to close your eyes truly I know it
sounds stupid but I want you to close
your eyes and I want you to in your mind
have a specific picture of what it looks
like in your life when your self-worth
has improved you're gonna see yourself
speaking up at work you're gonna see
yourself talking more about your
business you're gonna see yourself
leaving bad relationships you're gonna
see yourself defining boundaries you're
gonna see yourself going to the gym
you're gonna see yourself taking care of
yourself and when you start to visualize
the image of that I want you to
consciously this is step to consciously
think of the positive emotions that
you're gonna feel I'm gonna feel happy
I'm gonna feel proud I'm gonna stand
taller I'm going to be so grateful that
I made this change marrying the the
specific picture oh there I am there I
am I'm I'm it I'm at work and I'm
raising my hand amazing
I'm sharing my tea there I am I'm
getting a promotion there I am asking
for a raise there I am I've just signed
up another customer to my business there
I am I've gone back to school I feel so
good about myself when you do that
here's what's actually happening in your
brain this is the cool science part you
are training your brain to have a
totally different filter you see your
brain my brain it doesn't know the
difference between something that
actually happened to you like the f you
got in your test in tenth grade and the
things you imagine that are happening to
you let me say that again your brain
doesn't know the difference between the
bad things that actually happen to you
the real memories that you have and an
imagined memory that you're creating
your brain will experience you
visualizing going to the gym you visual
how happy you feel when you do you
visualizing asking for that raise and
getting it and how proud you're going to
feel your brain when you visualize in
the way that I'm teaching you to it it
encodes it as a real memory and that's
important because when you encode it as
a real memory it changes the filter
system that reticular activating system
and here's what we know based on
research the more you visualize things
number one the greater your confidence
is going to be the greater security
you're gonna have about it and here's
the really cool thing the more you do
this with your goals you wake up every
day and you just visualize four it takes
30 freaking seconds for crying out loud
you visualize having a great day at
school you visualize curing your panic
and how proud you're going to be what
studies suggest and have proven is that
simply visualizing yourself doing things
actually develops the skill and helps
you improve the skills just as if you
were actually doing it rule number 36
stop complaining Deborah says what about
complaining about things that genuinely
take time to resolve like I'm getting
over being sick let me ask you a
question does complaining about being
sick actually help you get better it's a
fair question you're allowed to complain
if it's productive if it makes you feel
better to go and saying it is helpful
terrific if doing that makes you feel
even worse try not to do it say things
like boy I'm on day three of this I must
be getting better
boy the meds are gonna kick in at any
moment you know when it starts chris is
looking at me like what are you talking
about just somebody mentioned do
thoughts count yes outbound sort of out
we're complaining yes complaining in
your own mind of course thoughts count
because you know what you complain about
the most yourself your body your
intelligence what you just said the fact
that you didn't go to the gym the fact
that you didn't do what you said you
were gonna do the beating yourself up as
a form of complaining because you're
expressing dissatisfaction for yourself
and the problem with all this is that
when you do it habitually or when you
complain as just a default mode and you
don't realize how much you're doing it
you're allowing your mind to filter the
world a certain way and you're allowing
yourself to live in existence where your
own thoughts are poisonous if you feel
like hell and you got the flu and you've
just thrown up in the toilet complain
all you want vent all you want you just
earned that but at some point you're
gonna have to stop feeding the monster
and putting poison in your own mind and
you're gonna have to teach yourself how
to start to find milestones that are
positive so that you can become
healthier so that you can change how you
think rule number 37 do the things that
make you happy you born your home and
then we go to kindergarten and then you
go to first grade and then you go to
second grade and then you go to third
grade and then you go to fourth grade
and then you go to fifth grade and then
you go to middle school and then you go
to high school and then there's the
pressure to go to college or to a tech
school or to do something else and then
you get your job and then you're in your
job and then you meet somebody and then
you get married and then you're supposed
to buy the house and then you're
supposed to have the kids and maybe you
get the dog before the kids or after the
kids but then you have a second kid and
then you have the 0.5 kid because most
of us do point five kids and then we get
and then we get the the home equity line
and then we put the kitchen Edition on
and then we I mean it's like our entire
lives are set out in this linear
progression as people chase the dream
the next and particularly for
those of us who are triggered by the
fear of losing control it's only natural
to anchor your feeling of being in
control to chasing the next thing and so
not only are we all socialized to
believe that we're supposed to climb
this ladder we're supposed to do things
in a linear progression we're supposed
to get to the next thing we've also been
marketed to by society that will be
happier if we have a new car we'll be
happier if we have a better dishwasher
we'll be happier if we have the skin
lotion that's got the almond scent and
we are also psychologically anchoring
our sense of control and our sense of
happiness on achieving those things and
what you're experiencing is no different
than what millions and millions and
millions of us experience and that's
that emptiness that you feel when you
buy the lotion that smells like almond
butter and it doesn't make you happy or
you get the promotion and you have an
extra hundred bucks in your paycheck
after taxes and it means you can buy the
$14 Chardonnay not the $10 short and
Chardonnay and it doesn't make you happy
and the reason why is the I'll be happy
when life the chase the carrot life the
get to the next thing life that form of
happiness requires you to be driving
let's use the car analogy again to be
going 60 miles an hour at all times
and happiness is achieved through a
different formula it happens when you're
sitting at the light and you're idle
when you're in the moment doing things
that make you happy and that's being
with people that you care about it's
engaging in experiences that make you
happy and it's just working on things
that are important to you rule number 38
learned to deal with negativity
and on YouTube how do I protect myself
from negative people at work while
trying to be positive so I think about
forcefields you there are certain people
in your life that are negative that you
can't avoid there are probably people at
work just like Amanda has that are
negative that you can't avoid cuz you
got to work with them there might be
people in your family there might be
people in your household there might be
roommates that you have or people in the
classes that you're taking that are
negative think about force fields
because energy is contagious just
because somebody else is negative
doesn't mean you have to let their
negativity seep through into you my
greatest tool in dealing with negative
people is to feel sorry for them I know
it's a judgy thing to do but I feel like
if I've got this negative person in my
life or around me or at the coffee shop
or whatever
isn't it interesting around negative
people they sort of vibrate this
nastiness and this passive-aggressive
stuff and they're like body language is
all like instead of letting that seep
into you what you want to do is get the
force fields up and get yourself above
that person so you can look at them and
basically go whoa I wonder what happened
to that person that would make them so
negative I wonder what that person's
life or home life is like that they walk
into work and they feel like this feel
sorry for them there's something about
feeling sorry for somebody else or
asking yourself to have what happened to
that person to turn them into such a
negative look and to be so hurt that
kind of perspective elevates you above
the toxicity rule number 39 resolve your
inner conflicts I was struggling with
anxiety I was ridiculously competitive
deeply insecure those three that
trifecta is dead
so very toxic human being and I think a
lot of it was an outgrowth of an
incident when I was in fourth grade and
I was molested by another kid and it was
not as traumatic of an incident as a lot
of people have survived but it what
happened as I look back I now understand
my full psychology but one of my
fundamental philosophies is that most of
us are dealing with some kind of
internal conflict that we have never
resolved because something happened to
us when we were little yeah and we did
something to survive it and that
survival mechanism mine happened to be
lying but that survival mechanism worked
when you were a kid it worked to keep
you safe it worked to keep your abusive
dad from not screaming at you
it worked to make people like you but as
you got older you never updated that
strategy and so a lot of people that we
serve that I work with whether they are
the CEO of a publicly-traded company or
they are a kid just graduating from high
school or hoping to graduate from high
school the number one thing that most
people are dealing with is they're
dealing with unresolved internal
conflicts about that happened when they
were a kid and what happened to me when
I was a kid is I had this incident
happen where I was abused by another kid
again not as like scary as what a lot of
people deal with and when I went
downstairs in the morning after it
happened
my mom was standing there and she turned
to me and said oh hi had it just sleep
honey
and I saw out of the corner of my eye
that the kid that had done it to me was
sitting at the table and I immediately
said fine and that moment right there
when I said fine I made a decision not
to say what happened because I didn't
want her to get upset I didn't want
there to be a scene I didn't want to get
in trouble I mean this is like a fourth
grader processing processing yeah it
solidified
a strategy that I used literally until I
was in my mid-30s and that strategy was
don't tell the truth assess and say
whatever it is that is going to kind of
calm the waters or make people happy and
so I became somebody that literally was
driven by looking around and making sure
everything was okay and not wanting to
upset people and I was very competitive
and outgoing but it was not the kind of
competitive and outgoing that I am today
that's grounded in confidence and that's
grounded in my values it was a
competitiveness and an outgoingness that
was based in insecurity
rule number 40 have a good morning
routine why is the morning routine so
important a couple things
how you wake up has a scientifically
proven impact on your ability to focus
on your happiness and on your
productivity all day the two to three
pieces of it are for me I wake up when
the alarm goes off I then get up and for
the first couple minutes of the day I
plan my day and I have a particular
process that I go through that leverages
something from Harvard Business School
called the progress principle I have a
mindfulness practice that could be
anything that you want it could be
gratitude journaling it could be
meditation it could be five slow deep
breaths it could be taking your your dog
outside for a walk and then on mornings
when I can I have a micro exercise
practice where I do planks for five
minutes or I do something to get my
blood pumping on the mornings that I can
I and I do all that before I ever even
look at my phone because I put myself
and my mindset first deliberately before
I ever allow the world access to my mind
you do not want anybody to have access
to what's going on up here until you've
gotten deliberate about what you're
thinking about first rule number 41 you
the five-second rule so the five-second
rule is a self coaching tool that's all
that it is and it's something that I
invented literally 20 feet from here in
my bedroom although that bedroom wasn't
built back then it was something that I
invented to beat my habit of hitting the
snooze button hmm and the way that it
works is very simple
the moment that you need to do something
and you can feel yourself hesitating and
you can feel the excuses rolling in
count backwards to yourself 5 4 3 2 1
and something weird will happen the
moment you get to one you'll actually
move and I invented it by mistake I
invented it during I think the worst
moment of my life which was 2008 Chris
and I my husband of 22 years we were
about to lose everything
well his restaurant business was going
under I had just been fired from a job
my first job in the media business so I
was just wallowing and self-doubt
because I thought boy have I really
screwed up I had changed my career
taking a risk gone into the media
business it didn't work out I felt like
a total loser I felt like I made a big
mistake we had three children mortgage
to pay the entire house had been used to
leverage the business so it our life
savings so at the kid's college savings
I mean just on the verge of losing it
all Chris was sleeping on the couch and
I just couldn't get out of bed
and so I invented this thing the
five-second rule one night when I saw a
rocket ship fly across a television
screen at the end of a commercial and it
gave me this idea and the idea was hmm I
wonder if I launched myself out of bed
so fast I wonder if I could move fast
enough that I could beat the self-doubt
and anxiety that I felt every single
morning when I would wake up and it was
really that dumb and that simple of an
idea and for whatever reason when the
alarm went off that next morning what
happened is what happens to all of us
all day long
inspiration strikes so the alarm goes
off and used the thus knew who use the
alarm clock as a metaphor for those
moments when you know you should do
something and the alarm goes off and
what's interesting is most of us don't
have a problem with what we need to do
it's how we make ourselves do this
that's hard so the alarm went off and
immediately my mind woke up and my mind
started spinning as our minds do and I
started immediately thinking like most
of us do when the alarm goes off I don't
want to get up on is you know it's cold
I don't want to get the face that day
I'm an employee and then the body starts
to kind of get a little tense when
anxiety comes in or you start to feel
overwhelmed about this you got to deal
with and I felt myself reaching for the
snooze alarm like I always did but that
morning I went 5 4 3 2 1 and by the time
I hit one I was standing up and I was
kind of freaked out because why would
something so simple work but I went on
with my day and I used it the next
morning and the next morning the next
morning and then I started to wonder god
I see that it works as a cheat for the
alarm clock but I wonder if it could
work for other things so I started to
use it for every moment in my life where
I knew what to do but I didn't feel like
it
5 4 3 2 1 literally just decimates any
excuse that you have and as I started to
use it in my life - 5 4 3 2 1 not be an
[ __ ] - Chris 5 4 3 2 1 turn and walk
away from the Bourbon and not have a
drink 5 4 3 2 1 pick up the phone and
network 5 4 3 2 1 walk out the door and
go to the gym everything changed because
my decisions changed
rule number 42 own your dreams you know
what my dream was my dream someday was
to be a talk-show host and I was always
embarrassed to admit it because it
seemed so implausible I mean it seemed
how on earth doesn't want to even do
that and see that's the the
thing about dreams is that your dreams
they matter and in order to achieve them
you're going to have to be able to have
the courage to be brave enough to
actually state what your dreams are
because if you can't own them you don't
deserve them rule number 43
don't make busyness a habit let me talk
to you about Dan so Dan was the first
person and take control that I coached
and he is a super successful guy he
loves what he's doing right now he is I
think the world's best phys ed teacher
he's a total pro at it he loves his
students he's been doing it a long time
but he is starting to panic about the
next chapter of his life he's starting
to panic about the fact that you know
time is ticking and I love what I do but
I'm not sure this is my true calling how
do I figure it out how do I make sure
that I don't wake up at the age of 70 or
80 or 90 and realize that I never
actually went for the thing that I
really love and a lot of times going for
the thing that you really love doesn't
mean quitting your job
it means figuring out how to be more
focused and deliberate in your life so
that you can start to add in incremental
progress every day on inching forward
that side hustle that passion project
that book you've always wanted to write
and so one of the first takeaways from
Dan's coaching session one of the first
takeaways is busyness and we take a look
at the fact that yeah there are a lot of
you that are really busy because you got
a lot going on and then there is the
type of busyness that we keep in our
lives because by being busy you
convinced yourself that you're in
control by being busy you fill up your
life so much that you also also have an
excuse for never ever ever having the
time to do the thing that scares you
which is to write the book start that
passion project work on your side hustle
and
got to be very careful if you're
somebody who feels like you're busy all
the time to understand that busyness can
become a habit and busyness can become
your biggest excuse rule number 44
discover your passion
the problem with passion is that you and
I have bought into this massive fantasy
world where we think that passion is a
person or a place or a thing that
somehow like a needle in a stay has a
needle in a haystack that you are
somehow just going to stumble into the
thing and you're gonna find that one
person are you gonna find that one thing
that you're meant to do or you're gonna
find that career and honestly we got to
change the way that you think about
passion and purpose before you will
actually be able to bring it into your
life because the truth is passion isn't
in a person it isn't in a place and it
isn't in a thing it's something inside
of you and when you flip the definition
of what passion is and when you actually
understand what you're looking for when
you say I want to discover my passion
then you'll be able to create more of it
in your life
rule number 45 make energizing decisions
people can smell a phony a million miles
away and what will make you successful
is following the thing that naturally
energizes you because it's unique
yeah and when your energy is expansive
you will naturally attract people that
want that same feeling yeah it's really
that simple it doesn't feel that simple
when you're stuck I get that yeah and I
can sit here and say it's that simple
but I'm 27 years into the trajectory of
figuring it out but hell I wish I had
known this when I was anything yeah I
would have saved myself a world of hurt
rule number 46 takes small actions every
day the one person that is diminishing
your ability to make these dreams a
reality is you because when you state
your dream this is what happens you
state it and then all of a sudden you're
present - how far away you are from it
and when you see the distance between
where you are and where you want to go
the direction that your dream requires
you to walk in you're going to get
present to the gap and that scares us
that's where fear comes into play and
you start to think of all the reasons
why you don't deserve it you start to
think of all the reasons why you can't
do it all that you have to do in order
to start to pursue your dreams is take
small actions every day that align your
life in that direction so what does that
mean if you want to play guitar
professionally it means that you start
playing guitar more it means that you
sign up for open mic nights it means
that you go back to classic if that's
something that interests you you see
your dreams will happen either because
of you or in spite of you they don't
happen because of other people they
happen because of you and what you do
the second you have the bravery to state
that dream now are you going to create
it or are you gonna diminish it in your
mind
rule number 47 roll with the punches
those of us that are out there in the
world doing big things that one of the
reasons why we're able to do big things
is because we have trained ourselves to
just push forward even when things are
not the way that you want them to be
going to keep your cool too
roll with the punches even when you
don't have the support that you need and
so you know I had something happen
yesterday I was in the middle of giving
a speech so imagine this you're on stage
you are twenty minutes into your speech
you have 40 more minutes to go you have
30 more slides to go to which is what
was happening at that point and all of a
sudden my laptop dies I mean just blank
you guys so I've got an entire audience
I'm through the first third of my speech
I have two-thirds of the speech to go
and my speech is a story that has a ton
of videos and photos in it and my laptop
died and what had happened is the AV
team had plugged the laptop into a
podium that had no power in it so my
laptop was set up correctly it was
plugged in but it was plugged into
something that had absolutely no power
source so over the course of the hour
before the tech check to when I was on
the stage the laptop has run out of
juice and so all of a sudden Here I am
completely cold laptop I just you know
had this moment where I thought the
first thing in my mind was holy cow what
am I gonna do for the next 40 minutes
and I could feel my stomach start to go
crazy and the butterflies to kick in and
it just wow I was I was extremely
panicked for about a second and then I
was like okay use the tools use the
tools don't don't get nervous get
excited because you can show everybody
what looks like in front of a live
audience to have a massive technical
breakdown and not lose your cool and so
I made a joke about it the a/v team ran
up I said look you guys have no power
here so take it back there get it
plugged in and I'll talk for two or
three minutes while you get this thing
set up now meanwhile I'm thinking while
I'm talking to a live audience what if
they don't get this set up what am I
going to do how am I going to fill the
40 minutes when the hosts
is not only anchored in the story but
it's anchored in all of these
photographs and proof of people's
stories from around the world and so I'm
like don't panic don't panic use the
tools now and then all of a sudden the
guy shouts out what's your password you
know because my my screen was locked so
then I thought okay we're gonna get this
done not a problem it took about five
minutes for things to get back up and
running and it was one of the longer
five-minute periods of my life but I got
through it and one of the reasons why I
got through it is because I've trained
myself to roll with the punches
that's what I've trained myself to do
rule number 48 feel the fear and do it
anyways
Heather is held back at work because
what happens is when she has to have a
really difficult conversation when
there's something that she wants to talk
to her boss about when there's a
conflict with one of her colleagues you
ever have a conflict with your
colleagues at work ever feel like you
work in a toxic work environment well
this is something that you need to
understand sometimes the toxicity in
your work environment is about the other
people and sometimes the toxicity in
your work environment or in your life
environment or your friend environment
is about stored memories in your body
from your childhood I know it's crazy
stuff because the saying feel the fear
and do it anyway it's true because your
body feels situations that set you that
puts you in a state of being afraid
before your mind catches up and starts
thinking about what you're afraid of and
so one of the key takeaways from take
control and one of the things that I
want to teach you today is that if you
start to tune into your body and you
start to notice the signals that your
body is sending to you in your day to
day life signals like butterflies in
your stomach signals like feeling a rush
of energy up to your neck signals like
your armpits sweating signals like your
hands getting sweaty signals that your
body is stepping and noticing a
situation
that reminds it of your past learning
how to read those signals that oh my god
here goes my body my body is starting to
recognize that this is a situation that
puts me on edge recognising those
signals first and slowing the body
response down before your brain starts
to go oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god
that is a critical skill in taking
control of your life
rule number 49 being real everything we
talk about has to be proven right
everything I love that I don't give you
some [ __ ] I've read in a book or
something that I've read on Instagram
the only things that we share are things
that are backed by science that have
been researched that we have seen
working in our own lives that we see
working for our audience and I think
that is critical because let's face it
anybody can put up a inspirational quote
you know that they've read from somebody
else anybody can tell you to you know be
positive or do this or put in the work
or hustle or whatever the hell it may be
at the end of the day it's just talk
yeah you have to know how yeah and I
also am you know somebody who is a
little bit cynical so you know I'm sort
of embarrassed that I'm in self-help on
some level because he sounds stupid
right you know I mean I come from I I
mean I I'm older than you I'm almost 50
self had a really bad name
20 years ago yeah and I also am Ivy
League yeah lawyer yeah and I am an
entrepreneur there's a lot of [ __ ] I
mean there's a lot of there's a lot of
fake out there sure I had renting houses
in Rory's been telling you if you use
their click final strategy or whatever
strategy that you'll be rich like they
are and yeah you may and chase the money
if it energizes you there but there's a
lot of smoke in there and rule number 50
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is slowed down for many of us
slowing down is really scary but that's
exactly what you need to do and so if
you are always in a rush
feel like there's urgency in your life
if you move at a pace that makes you
feel panicked or rush you've got a
million things to do and you think that
you're busy but you're not productive
the solution is not doing more it's
doing less it's not speeding up it's
actually slowing down because being busy
doesn't mean you're in control it means
you're being driven by this fear of
slowing down
you're being driven by the fear that
when you slow down you're gonna have to
confront where you're at and you're
gonna have to start doing the work and
that can be scary but you take control
of your life not by speeding up
everybody but by slowing down you take
control of your life by removing
distraction and adding in focus you take
control of your life by being honest
with yourself about the things that
you're filling your life with it doesn't
matter that makes you so busy and that
also prevents you from finding the 15
minutes that you need every day to
really find the courage to focus on
making your life a little bit better or
pushing something forward if you're
somebody who's guilty of being busy and
never having the time to do the thing
that really matters to you that your
hearts calling you to do or you never
have the time to do something to take
care of yourself I want you to find 15
minutes today and I want you to slow
down
whether you've always thought about
meditating and you've never done it
download the combat listen to it do one
guided meditation go for a walk for 15
minutes just a quiet walk without your
phone or with your phone turned off have
a cup of tea or a cup of top coffee and
read something listen to a podcast for
15 minutes take a bath tonight something
where you experienced the sensation of
slowing down because again busyness
becomes a habit and when it becomes a
habit it becomes an epidemic and when it
becomes an epidemic it will rob you of
your ability to take control of your
life and at the root cause of all of
this is fear just the fear of slowing
down because when you slow down and you
start to create priorities and you start
to take control now you're responsible
for what's happening your life and you
can no longer rely on just complaining
that you're busy now I've got a special
bonus tip from Mel
on how to not let friends stop your
growth that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
where do you need to just slow down
number two what does b-real look like to
you and number three where do you need
to feel the fear and do it anyways if
you have friends that make you wrong for
changing your life for the better that's
their issue it's not yours and so you
got to untangle the fact that they have
baggage about getting in shape or they
have baggage about going to the bar
that's theirs and it has nothing to do
with the decisions that you're making so
if your friends in general give you
blowback for changing for the better
what you need to say in the back of your
mind is interesting they're obviously
very conflicted about their choice to go
to the bar and drink every night but
that has nothing to do with me here's
the other thing you can do if they start
to make you wrong you can say well you
want to go to plan a fit which was me
instead it doesn't sound like you want
to be at the bar
so that said let me talk to you a little
bit about friends friends are people
that you care about and I have this test
I call it the funeral test if somebody
in your life were to die
ask yourself would I go to their funeral
if the answer is yes their friend of
yours that's the test for whether or not
in my opinion someone is a friend
because it means you care about them now
here's the other thing about friendship
that I want you to understand you can
care about somebody and not like hanging
out with them and that's the situation
that you're in right now that you have
plenty of friends
that you care about if they were to die
you would go to their funeral if they
needed you you would be there if you saw
them you'd be happy to see them but you
don't like to hang out with them the
other thing that I want you to think
about is that and that's okay that's
like a normal part of friendship and the
reason why that's a normal part of
friendship is because one of the things
that we know about life is that you're
always going to be changing in the old
pattern and the old chapter you had
certain patterns right in the old
chapter of your life you would go to the
bar and drink you would go to the store
and spend money you didn't have you're
in a new chapter now and so you have
different patterns when your life takes
on different patterns where
it's you're no longer going to the bar
you're going to the gym the pattern
might even be that one of your kids is
playing with a different soccer team or
maybe you've moved to a different Street
in your town when the patterns change so
will your circle of friends it's a fact
of life but that doesn't mean your old
friends the ones that used to drink with
aren't friends anymore it just means
that you don't want to hang out with
them you still care about them but you
don't like doing what they do the
patterns have changed for a long time I
had a lot of drama around this until I
realized that it's not personal it's not
personal that you don't want to hang out
with them patterns in your life have
simply changed the final thing that I
want to leave you with that may also
help you is that remember I've given you
the funeral test if you'd go to their
funeral they're definitely a friend it
means you care about them but you might
not like hanging out with them that much
and that's cool that's normal the other
thing that I want you to think about
when it comes to friendships is you can
typically put friends into three buckets
you got friends for a reason you got
friends for a season and you have
friends for a lifetime and one of the
interesting things that I know about my
own life is that as the patterns of my
life change so do the friends that I
hang out with more frequently and I also
believe that as you change and the
patterns in your life change people show
up in your life for a reason the right
people will show up when you start going
to the gym the right people that you
need for the pattern that you're in
right now will start showing up when
you're working on your project instead
of shopping and it's exactly the kind of
people that you need they're there for a
reason and the Friends of yours that are
friends of yours for a lifetime I bet
you don't hang out with them that much
at all anyway but I bet they're the
first person that you call when you need
to talk to somebody about somebody
important those are the friends for a
lifetime and those folks that are still
sitting at the bar and love to blow
money that they don't have those were
friends for a season if you want to
learn how to change your life with the
five-second rule check out their video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there you only feel motivated to
do the things that are easy lean into
your passion and you've got to really
take some risks and you've got to feel
the fear and you got to do it